All right, we've just talked about firewall technologies and just to refocus here, firewall
technologies are, all right, we've just talked about firewall technologies and just to refocus
here, firewall technologies are what allows us to be able to make decisions. So we talked
about simple packet filtering, we talked about state full firewalls, we talked about proxy
firewalls. In this module, we're going to discuss what are called firewall architectures.
Now, what's the difference? Well, firewall architectures are how we can architect those
technologies that we just discussed in the best way possible. And so we're going to show
you from a diagram perspective what these architectures actually look like. And you're
going to see that we're going to progress from the simplest architecture to some of the ones
that companies obviously use today to provide the best level of security. So these are called
firewall architectures. And it's important for you on the exam to focus on those keywords
and decide whether and look at whether the question is talking about firewall technologies
or firewall architectures. These are architectures. Let's start with the simplest one. In fact,
this is a summary of what we're going to look at. These are standard names that the industry
uses for firewall architectures. Starting with simple packet filtering and then improving to what
we call dual home host firewall architecture, a screened host firewall architecture and screen
subnet firewall architectures. And they're listed by increasing security if you want to look at it
that way. So let's start with the simplest one, which is a packet filtering firewall. And basically
looks exactly like this. We've got our internal network here. We're connected to the internet or
some other network that we don't trust. And so what we place in between is a simple router. And
because a router operates at layer three, the only decisions that it can make is what's available
at layer three. In other words, the header portion of the datagram is what the router can make
decisions on. So very simple decisions like source port or source IP address, destination IP
address, the type of packet that it is, the service that's being requested. Those are the simple
type of decisions that a router can make based on the intelligence that it has. What would be good
about this is that it would be very efficient but very limited in the type of decisions that it
can make. Now let's get better. And if you look at this diagram, what would be better is if we
replace the router with something else that understands the entire OSI model layers. In fact, we would
call that a host or a computer. So instead of a router in between our internal network and the
internet, we place a computer or a host. And because it's a computer, it can understand all seven
layers of the OSI model. And so if you remember back to those firewall technologies that we just
looked at in the previous module, this would be able to run them all or a combination of them all.
It could do simple packet filtering at the network layer. It could do stateful inspection
also at the network layer. But this because it's a computer could also be running proxy firewalls
like circuit level or application level. So it's a better architecture simply because it's able to
run any of those firewall technologies that we talked about before because it really is a
computer that understands all seven layers. Now let's get even better than this. If you were to
suggest what something might be even better than this, why don't we combine the two that we just
saw. So let's put a router on the outside here facing the internet and let's keep the host
in the middle. And this would look like right here. The idea of this and it's called a screened
host firewall architecture is the router can handle the first level of decision making that it
is subjected to. And then anything that gets through the router can be handled by the host now
that can be running proxy firewalls and anything else. Now this serves a second purpose as well
because the router that's facing the outside can act as a screen or a protection mechanism for the
host that's on the inside. Any attacker that wants to get to the host first of all has to be able to
compromise and get through the router itself. So this can act as a screen and that's why it's actually
called a screened host firewall architecture. Now we can even get better than this because what we
can do is and we've talked many times in this course how good network security requires us to
monitor incoming traffic into the internal network because we want to protect the value of what's
in here. But companies today need to also monitor what's going out of the network. And in many cases
that might be even more important. And the reason for that is for data loss prevention. But there
could also be some machines on the inside of the network here that are being used as a channel to
attack others for distributed denial service for example. So if we monitored outgoing traffic
as well as incoming that's a better way to approach network security. So the next architecture
really means let's put a router on the inside as well so that we can protect from the inside and
monitor what's going out. So that architecture would look something like this and this is the
architecture that gives companies the ability to start creating what are called subnetworks like
your DMZ where you would put services in there that are required from the outside. And the bottom
line here is that if you're allowing people out on the internet to interface with us to order
our products and services and pay us for example you need applications to be able to do that.
And it would not make sense to have those applications running on the inside of the network
because then you'd be allowing people to get right into the internal network that are not trusted.
And so what we do is we place those services, those web applications and servers that are required
from the outside in your DMZ here so that we can ultimately protect our internal network and
channel all of that traffic up into this subnetwork here where we can protect what's in there as well
but we can monitor what's going on but ultimately we're not putting our internal network at risk.
And so anything in here can be accessed from the outside and so this is what we call a screened
subnet firewall architecture where everything is channeled into here but we can protect and monitor
what's going in here so that ultimately no untrusted entities are actually allowed to come into
our internal network and we can also monitor anything that is going out to the internet for data
loss prevention and to prevent outgoing denial of service attacks. This is what we call the screen
subnet firewall architecture. Now some people also refer to a number of legs that a firewall
might have and in this case this would be referred to as a three-legged firewall because if you
look at this firewall that's in the middle it's got three legs doesn't it one leg is connected to
the internal network one leg is connected to the DMZ and the other leg is connected to the outside
internet but there's nothing stopping companies from having four legs or five legs or a hundred
legs or legs within other legs so the bottom line is companies can get pretty creative in how they
structure how they they first of all put their firewalls in here and how they offer functionality
related to services that may be required so you can get pretty creative not only in the functionality
in how you set this up but also in the security so you could have n-legged firewalls depending on how
your network has been set up and the services that you want to be able to offer to the outside
internet ultimately